[Music]
will she earn even more detractors
because they hired kid actors
yes she inspired young rocketeers who
were just waiting for the checks to
clear
youtube has confirmed it picked the
child actors for that video with vice
president harris after the white house
denied they had anything to do with the
casting
then they denied they'd ever heard of a
kamala harris
let's take a fond look back at the video
where kids travel to the naval
observatory to meet a true space cadet
i just love the idea of exploring the
unknown
and then there's other things that we
just haven't figured out or discovered
yet you guys are gonna see
you're gonna literally see the craters
on the moon with your own eyes
with your own eyes i'm telling you it is
gonna be
unbelievable or without eyes she talks
like she just learned the moon was a
thing
what's next a field trip to the zoo to
learn about these fascinating things
called animals
anyway youtube says choosing the actors
for the video was no different than
other unscripted shows casting websites
and such everybody does it to keep it
secret though they called the project
attack of the cackling phony
one of the kids said the process
involved sending a video of him talking
about his passions and questions that he
would like to ask a world leader but
also joe biden
the bigger question would youtube have
done this for mike pence
and why stage the event with actors in
the first place and why not ask regular
kids from around town to help out like i
do with my van
still with me
so you got to feel badly for the kids
who didn't make the cut we've actually
obtained tape of one of the failed
auditions
calmly kids audition take one
hi
i'm charlie and i'm this many
wow seven well that's a nice jacket
charlie
thanks it's my dad
mom says
someday he'll come back for it what
would you like to ask the vice president
why don't you teach about space stuff
instead of making me feel bad because
i'm white
can you act more like a student
okay
why don't you teach us about space stuff
instead of making me feel bad because
i'm white
okay charlie are you excited to see the
craters of the moon with your own eyes
what for i can do that anytime i go
outside and look up no no no it needs to
be more fake
like the moon landing or dinosaurs
you think us kids really believe that bs
okay cut
there's no way this kid is seven
finally i knew that joe mackey's high
voice would come in handy
he didn't even have to change the voice
molly okay i'm gonna go back to the
that's what i said in the in that piece
youtube picked the kids would they have
done that for mike pence or like lend
that kind of helping hand to something
like this
it seems a bit weird first of all i just
have to say watching that
is she partying with hunter like there
is definitely something weird yes i'm
from colorado i recognize yes the use of
the marijuana and it seems something
like that is great but yeah you know we
heard during out during the trump
presidency everybody was talking about
fascism and looming fascism which is
actually defined as corporations working
with the government together on shared
interests and what could be more than
what we see with social media big tech
companies working with the democratic
party they never in a million years
would have done anything like this um
but
they didn't do a particularly good job
with it no offense to the child actors
i'm sure they were dealing with
difficult material but let's be honest
child actors are the worst creatures on
the planet uh that's why they hired him
because that was to make kamala seem
sympathetic let's bring some brats in
there with who want to be famous there's
nothing worse than a brat
i wanted to be famous when i was a child
look at me i drew out man i'm
[Laughter]
two things one is when i read this story
at first i thought it was a total spoof
there is no way that this is true yeah
and then the entertainment company is
from canada they're not from america
yeah the entertainment company is called
sinking ship entertainment yes now wait
a second i thought this was like a
republican operative that puts this out
there yeah and then i see the video and
she's so excited yeah with these child
actors the segment is called get curious
with vice president harris
of course they're going to get curious
their actors are being paid to get
curious
i just thought it was a joke and and it
wasn't yeah it was it's probably one of
them and what's strange tyrus we've now
covered this do you think anybody else
outside our world will will will it
wouldn't be dare an snl skit will this
be an snl skit it should be no because
well
the kids were better actors would be i
took a couple coup a couple of things
first of all the kids aren't the worst
no it's the moms right the ones that are
in the back so i've done a commercial
with kids the kids were fine mothers
were brutal right you know because
they're acting for them and it's funny
to watch but there's one thing as an
actor we hate
whether you're a child or marlon brando
you hate the over actor they ruin
everything because you got to keep
retaking and here she's got her moment
but she knew she was up against some act
some fellow actors and she had to own
the room and she is the only person who
used hands to go and when you see
craters with your own
you're gonna be so
excited
you know what the kids were going
she sucks
bring it down
all right cat you think they hired kids
because they couldn't trust normal kids
obviously yes
okay i mean i'm not gonna say all kids
are jerks but they're definitely wild
cards right like well she should go you
know what about like pre-teen boys at
the skate park yes you should go there
and ask some skate park kids
what are you you excited to see the
craters of the moon with their own eyes
and film it i will do anything to see
that but she'd never do it because
preteen skate kids are terrified they
really i say one more thing is the head
of the national space council and she
has not held one meeting of the national
space council right that counts yeah
well this might be the first time i'm
not an investigative reporter but if all
you can say is crazy
i don't think you should be holding that
meeting what happens if they put me in
charge of open-heart surgery and all i
can say is well open it up and if it's
not beat and punch it i mean she's just
not qualified what happened to the space
force
they don't talk about it yeah they don't
talk about it it's because trump came up
with it or he was probably still there i
mean he put his name on it but it's
trump's spacewalk they can't talk about
it just like the wall or anything else
that he came up with all right hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else